[Music]
in got cotton ooh hahaha submitted by
Shelby Fran from htx where's that
Houston
Oh cowboy YouTube star Austin Jones was
arrested for convincing underage fans to
send him sexually explicit video come on
just such a awesome joke how they are
starve I don't know who they are I'm
sick I was yes he has over 500 cells
whoa what a [ __ ] bird so this is
awesome Jones he's known for singing he
already looks like solicits [ __ ] news
and [ __ ] like that
oh my god uh Sting's 24 years old you
had that look I thought it was underage
boys there's no like there's not
specific look but I don't know I don't
know how that guy think all guys know
like when guys see another dude you're
that [ __ ]
know what look look that's the look
right there wait the molesters look yep
see can you see the look in different
races too
yeah really but what is it what if and
chin has that look yeah Jason well
because Jason Canada Imelda same skin
tone that's why wears a black v-neck all
the girls got like teeny boppers fall
for they all had that love that look
[Music]
remember when I spit out always be good
ever since we were 10 I think it's like
clean-cut you can tell by just remember
like used to have that look but then you
saw like it everyone I love you to look
what they look young and innocent and
and still like virgin oh then you can
tell that they're men but they're like a
30 year older yeah if there's 25 trying
to look like you're 16 got it x2 that's
that look I'm talking about who's all
three where girls if you meet a dude and
he looks like a little pop star can you
find out he's 27 they like that yeah
they I know you girls count can't resist
yourselves but just to let you know they
are pedophile with every single girl at
some point in her life she thinks that
she she's more mature and older than she
really guy hate those [ __ ] dude is so
[ __ ] annoying
I'm actually really mature for my age
[Music]
people tell me I older than I really am
so when these little perverts come
around and they start hitting on them
they're like you see it validates my
point I am therefore they have that look
though you're still right dude here's
your nerve is so [ __ ] right yeah yeah
with the older man that - he's six years
old
yes surpassed that limit I tell you
about this one story though and nothing
to do with her trying to get with my
older men but she thought she was so
[ __ ] mature and this was at church
pitch me off right I said my turn so
we're at UH we're having a Bible study
right and this [ __ ] always thought she
was so much more mature than everybody
else our [ __ ] Bible study teacher
wasn't there he got sick so he couldn't
make it
so one usually when your Bible study
teacher stink right you don't have to
have Bible study anymore it's great I
don't want to learn about Jesus and so
he spoken like a true Christian right so
she comes out she goes know everybody
sit down today I'm a teachers Bible
study today
she [ __ ] whipped out a Bible and try
to give us a Bible said [ __ ] we're the
same age get the [ __ ] out of here
so I closed the Bible and I said [ __ ]
no and I walked
you really did yes I would not a very
what did she do Hut she just said that
she was like oh thank you no they made
like just also Paul by the way I was
behaving because they now I mean amateur
she was like you have dead [ __ ]
she's definitely one of those [ __ ]
that's like I'm so mature for my age if
I can't connect with guys my age because
they're just so childish I am i tough
yeah I do the flash all guys are [ __ ]
immature yes it's so true I didn't know
this it's just that the even the most
serious [ __ ] mature looking ones
they're putting up a front to get some
poonanny and then afterwards they're
going to giggle about it with their guys
actually the most mature guys are
actually the most immature guys I've
ever watched those entrepreneur
interviews not going to watch Elon Musk
talk about Tesla it goes yeah I put all
of my money in and I well what about
your family
I wasn't really thinking about that you
know like you have a 99% failure in in a
society when every single large car
company is turning down their electric
vehicle program yeah I was just going
against the grain I like to do what I
want it's literally a kid with a billion
dollars making decisions like a
five-year-old all guys are immature so
what we're saying is even money Iran
must Ilana that's so true he's just a
billionaire that thinks like a child
what makes me a man that I pay my bills
and I'm responsible for how I act is how
I act baby I still don't understand what
the purpose of man is anymore were you
talking about
women are highly capable now they what
guys it is valid
oh really have a sense of humor and we
make women and you guys are way too
serious and you guys know loosen the
[ __ ] you'll never make me laugh as much
as tits makes me not know had me in
tears you don't have me in tears because
you haven't elevated your humor level
yet yeah
your humors like did you see what I saw
Oh what does it matter if it's elevated
yes no because what property you up I'm
setting up by the time in 80 I remember
what you told me when you were 25 I get
it now
dad you've got some laughter yes okay
anyway what was his article about me
bring it back to this article so this
dude Austin Joan the creepy piece all
the molester it was about Milano that's
right nonetheless tell porn yes
how child are we talking about like
six-year-old while we're talking about
17 year old that looks 21 but then he
got himself in trouble because he
couldn't keep it in his pants really
about 14 year old still wears a 14 year
old looking like a 21 noodles cuz these
days they've been doing makeup and wear
clothes it's like oh you showed me where
those booty shorts
I ain't I'm gonna I'm not a molester but
damn that's wrong string like a little
girl can I bring this over no no no
she's gonna go home
nobody happy what is it I have a friend
who has another friend that at the age
of 14 and so this is what I said she she
was like well I I used to really like
her ex-boyfriend otherwise it was like
well he was like quote-unquote like
really mature he was super nice and
sweet as a wienie mature right what was
she was 14 and he was 18 and I said
right off the bat when I put a [ __ ]
loser
right because in my mind when you're in
high school there was no way Lou going
up right yeah
when I was 14 I was trying to date 21
year olds yeah and you go up that's
lesson what I said was at 18
you're a [ __ ] adult yeah 14 you just
got to do your heart yeah buddy you'll
talk about what the [ __ ] does it do this
guy come in common with a [ __ ] door
laughter that's what I said great why
you hear what this guy was saying though
he's like no I remember when he was
super sweet he was really nice yeah
cause he wanted baby [ __ ] dude he's a
[ __ ] perv oh boy Lester
good now I feel like I thought I was
crazy
although I'm not crazy no you're not
crazy he's so sweet he treated me letter
angle could you pause
okay continue I feel better now
thank you so much all right so this guy
awesome John to singer right he was on
tour he was arrested at the Chicago
airports coming back from Poland I'm
gonna be no [ __ ] all public like that
yes so he is right now facing 30 years
in prison
yes it's like this is [ __ ] serious
[ __ ] thing I didn't even hear about
this it's so crazy
do you know who he is I don't either
there's all these youtubers on freaking
jump Khan Academy is crazy I know if you
guys want to be great youtubers make
sure you go take jump cut Academy will
teach you guys how to be great youtubers
but do not explore your fans and get
nudes from underage girls make sure
they're overage yeah this guy so he's
facing two counts of a minimum of 15
years each and the count is production
of child pornography so what do you ask
them for like yo can you play with
yourself okay go tell you okay go go go
I'm just telling you serious that sounds
David he's been doing that the whole
time all right
this guy what he was doing is that he
was instructing the young girl he's
really young fans to make sexual videos
for him he would instruct them on what
to say oh my god what should do he's a
freak what to wear he'll everything so
you wrote a script for them this angle
no he did what he did he told him I want
you to say this and this and this while
repeating your age saying your name
clapping your booty cheeks together it
was [ __ ] disturbing so what's the age
turn them on the age turn them on he
would repeatedly tell them like repeat
your age at least three times for J or
get yo ass is only 14 years old and my
[ __ ] you
what is wait let me see let me tell you
more because there's so much okay go
I'll keep going this is this is crazy
I'm only 14 I'm sport oh he would
contact rings girls via Facebook or
iMessage I would lead into iMessage and
this was back in 2016 2017 but back in
2015 there was already talk about him
being a pedophile because there was this
girl that came out saying like you know
what awesome girls like back when I was
younger he told me to create these
twerking videos he even sent me a video
on how to twerk which I'm going to show
you guys right now of haen't working of
him teaching this girl how to tour
exchange that's [ __ ] mediatorial yeah
yeah I know you made a DIY video alright
so here we go oh what the [ __ ]
creepy did it feels like the first basic
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
real oh my god oh [ __ ] it awkward
there's actually another video that that
exists of him wearing a black shirt
doing pretty much the exact same thing
saying all sex is the [ __ ] first
freak in the world so it is hilarious I
cracked up too but think about it though
this guy was testing tutorial on how to
twerk how to make these 14 year old
girls clap their booty cheeks for him
that's [ __ ] up
I listen but this is tutorial it's the
best thing I've ever seen they need to
make that [ __ ] viral because not only
did he go into jail he should be
embarrassed
we should humiliate the [ __ ] out of this
guy that'd be Craig that's like him
coming up as like hey babe so I want you
to Center dick on camera so I bought
this man named yeah he's like got a
real-life doll and I want you to look
like this yeah so this video was exposed
few years ago but nothing really
happened oh my god when this video came
out two years ago he ended up calling
the girl that tweeted out this video and
well there's two separate girls right
one of them she contacted this other
Twitter user who then uploaded this
video and that Twitter user was getting
threats from Austin saying that he's
going to be suing him for like
defamation slandering analytics
information that was that right and then
this other girl she ended up putting it
out and then he called her and leaves
her a voicemail saying like please you
please delete that tweet like this is
ruining me whatever omission you were on
your cell phonee
this whole thing got messy and then for
some reason nothing happened but then
now he's been arrested and now there's
court documents and so there's two
victims involved in this and so a victim
a fourteen years old this will happen
when he was 24 years old she sent 15
videos to him one of them she where she
was sexually exposed you're the quote of
their conversation he told her quote go
make it clap super loud and talk about
your age the whole time got it and then
he talks down to her thing do you think
your butt is good enough to give guys
boners it hasn't given me a boner yet
that's why I'm concerned so because
we're dude so that conversation I just
said is here so I'll read it to you more
thoroughly so it says Austin says and
your honest opinion do you think your
boys good enough to give consumers
victim a says yes I have given guys
owners with it many times it's a 12 year
old conversation yeah it hasn't given me
a boner yet that's one concern she says
damn it he says I guess try harder add
more lines while you bounce if you think
that will help
victim says somehow how about I try no
underwear I won't show anything he says
you can try that so then he's like oh
bug they're flirting in that
conversation yeah and so that was with
her victim a victim be 14 years old this
happened when he was 23
she sent 25 videos 8 of them she was
sexually exposed a quote he told her was
do you realize how lucky you are I
shouldn't even be talking to you and so
then he tells her like she needs to
prove how much of a fan she is so he
says think how amazing that would be for
you to have your favorite senior spank
your ass if you're lucky maybe I let you
suck my dick
and then he requested her to repeat her
age multiple times in the video too soon
she says I'm just trying to help you I
know you're trying your hardest to prove
you're my biggest man and I don't want
to have to find someone else and then
hands up telling her I had to see your
butt hole to know for sure 100% care oh
good this sounds like honestly I need to
see your [ __ ] to double check that
you are a hundred percent man well you
know what Iowa big fan so let me show
you my butthole my fist this sounds like
uh I mean oh my god rack or but it
sounds like some like a comedic sketch
this sounds ridiculous like you you
can't write like you can't like the
scent well is that really you I need to
see the wink of your butthole like my
being catfished I need to see your
[ __ ] I couldn't ah laughs ugh yeah
but it is totally disturbing testing
this is [ __ ] ridiculous I don't go to
jail I forgot to mention back in 2015
when that whole first thing first came
out she ended up releasing a video
saying just like setting the record
straight or whatever and it's like this
long video of him just seeing all these
excuses like you've been through
depression use it to something I'm so
depressed that's why I need to see 14
year olds twerk it makes me happy
exactly that's like a youtuber excuse of
the
oh girl because I would talk video you
know what's really unique about this guy
he's a white guy I like booty oh that's
right you know it's working it's just
it's just mainstream now yeah but it's
flattering of the buttocks yeah yeah
white guys are known to like the potox
he doesn't look like she would like
twerking yeah but he knows and he knows
how to do it he's been practicing what
we want yeah in fact they keep the
[ __ ] Howcast DIY video on how to tour
now and like apparently when he got
arrested he waived his Miranda rights
and we start talking about
thank you talking about the text works
as a way out of the situation where he
admitted that he was engaged with
underage girls do you know what's gonna
happen to him in prison they're gonna
make him [ __ ] to work in front of
them in the shower and I'm gonna [ __ ]
him in the ass all [ __ ] yeah you're
gonna get [ __ ] up in prison
dude he's gonna be in jail twerking in
the in the shower while guys are telling
him what to do won't be a poppet holder
like that 25 25
you want me to clap harder this is up
god he's so weird
child molesters on the lowest of
hierarchy in jail right yeah he's going
to get [ __ ] up Matt and Mike Felicia
because there's a lot of dads in prison
you know with daughters and they don't
like that so be careful out there guys
and ladies
be careful hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discussed just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video click right up height
[Music]